bonjour philippe clair merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur sur rt france alors
vous êtes vous-même à one est ce que la
situation sur place est identique que
celle qu'on vient de présenter c'est à
dire plus aucun cas dans la ville de one
actuellement
bonjour de houran alors oui en effet
l'épidémie en fait on est passé en
dessous du seuil épidémique le jour où
on a des confiner la ville de l'oural
c'est à dire le 8 avril de cette année à
partir de là à commencer une période de
déconfinement extrêmement contrôlée avec
l'utilisation de moyens comme
l'intelligence artificielle et le
testing de façon à donner surtout
confiance à la population dans les dents
les dans les résultats qui avaient été
données par le gouvernement de façon à
ce que la vie économique reprenne et
aujourd'hui elle a repris totalement en
chine plus aucun c'est à dire
aujourd'hui vous vous confirmer ce qu'on
a dit précédemment
oui aujourd'hui il n'a plus de cas que
exporter ou importer si vous voulez
s'était dérouté cas qui sont arrêtés aux
frontières puisque la chine contrôle à
ses frontières de façon extrêmement
stricte l'entrée des étrangers ou des
chinois qu'ils rencontrent sur le
territoire national et donc les seuls
car politiques étaient des cadres deux
personnes revenant sur le territoire
chinois mines plus depuis de cassure
hanche une continental aujourd'hui nous
vivons ici à one s'en va ce qu'en dehors
d'aider des zones publiques comme le
métro il faut savoir que les chinois ne
portait pas de masque en tout cas haoran
auparavant aujourd'hui le porte toujours
mais c'est plutôt parce que ils ont eu
extrêmement peur je rappelle que la
chine a bloqué 69 personnes s'est éteint
un signal extrêmement fort pour sa
population la population à l'upr elle
est sur le coup de 2 de scandales
sanitaires ou paravent pour les poulets
médicaments pour des vaccins
donc on ne peut pas croire que la
population est docile elle est critique
mais le signal envoyé par le
gouvernement chinois le 23 janvier est
extrêmement puissant les chinois ont eu
peur
aujourd'hui il continuer de porter le
masque par sécurité ce même signal
employés par le gouvernement chinois
aurait glissé aurait dû servir à
l'occident pour montrer l'importance la
gravité de la situation
et justement en parlant de l'occident à
vous le savez l'europe et en particulier
la france et l'espagne connaissent une
deuxième vague de contamination
comment justement expliqué que ce soit
ne pas que ce ne soit pas le cas en
chine aujourd'hui
et bien parce que les chinois donc entre
le 17 février et le 8 avril ont pris des
mesures extrêmement efficace tout
d'abord de confinement strict en
arrêtant le brassage de population en
même temps il caractérise et des
patiences des sortes et tous les
patients qui étaient positifs et
contaminent peuvent nous contacter et
les soigner donc à ce moment là vous
vous retrouviez avec une population qui
n'avait plus de virus et vous passiez à
la phase de déconfinement qui est la
phase la plus importante ou là vous
remettez dans la france circulent à sion
donc une des personnes qui ne risquent
plus de contaminer d'autres personnes
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle et
grâce aux mesures barrières bien sûr et
le testing est-ce que selon vous les
pays européens où justement mal géré
cette épidémie les pays européens ont
subi l'épidémie et continuer à subir
l'épidémie dans le sens où lorsque vous
êtes confrontés aux chocs sanitaire
c'est à dire lorsque vos systèmes au
service de réanimation ne peuvent plus
prendre en charge les patients pour
d'autres pathologies qu'une seule
pathologie en l'occurrence le corona
buste est bien là vous êtes contraint au
confinement vous êtes contre et en
confirmant le mais le confinement les
chinois l'ont foulé n'est pas tout en
même temps que l'on confine on doit
appliquer une méthode et des moyens des
moyens importants de façon à permettre
un déconfinement sens sans virus sous
contrôle et un retour à la normale est
notamment un retour à la normale
économique parce que ça ça a été la
priorité des priorités pour les chinois
alors vous savez également actuellement
la bataille c'est celle d'un d'un vaccin
est aujourd'hui
les chinois avant sur ce sujet oui les
chinois sont en avance j'ai vécu donc en
tant qu'acteur et en tant que témoin
toute cette crise ici haoran une médecin
militaire chinoise s'est injecté un
premier essai de vaccin au mois de
février
vous pouvez dire que les chinois sont en
effet en avance nous sommes atteints en
phase iii en chine
c'est à dire que on est dans la phase de
décès du lac sur une grande population
donc il y à fort à parier que les
chinois seront les premiers à fabriquer
ce vaccin reste ensuite le problème de
confiance qui à mon avis est primordial
en chine il y aura peut-être une une une
conduire une contrainte si l'on puis
dire à être vaccinés dans les pays
occidentaux on sera obligé d'avoir la
confiance de la population pour une
vaccination qui atteint et d'avoir une
couverture qui a atteint le seuil
d'immunité collective et ça à mon avis
ce n'est pas gagné merci beaucoup fille
plaint d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france rappelle que vous êtes un
médecin et directeur d'une clinique dans
la ville de one merci beaucoup